daniel lynch takes the field
as a big leaguer for the first time and
there was a quite a roar from the crowd
when he was announced and daniel lin's
first pitch as a big leaguer is line to
center field
and dyson is there so daniel lynch
gets a big defensive play and i'm sure
he will never forget that look at his
smile on his face so
two outs now two walks and lynch will
get left hand hitting eddie rosario
fastball lined hard left field but right
there ben intended to make the catch
and daniel lynch needs a big sigh of
relief
and daniel lynch is now a member of that
exclusive club he's a big leader
indians royals no score and 25 year old
aaron savalli on the hill
he is 4-0 on the years pitch very well
making his sixth start
here's the hot andrew benintendi they're
not throwing strikes
and he gets the home stand started with
a line drive to right
he will hold with a single and the
royals have a runner at first with one
down
and a wild pitch puts ben and tendy in
scoring position now he'll needle with
salvador perez
curveball swung on hit fairly deep
angling toward the right center as the
center fielder and harold ramirez puts
it away
and this is a scoreless ball game tribe
and royals going to the second
as harold ramirez first ball swinging
drills one to deep left center
it'll bang off the wall and the first
major league at bat
in an indian's uniform for harold
ramirez
and he ropes a double off the wall to
the left of center that'll bring up josh
naylor
that's his first big league strikeout he
gets josh naylor
on three pitches so the ball salvador
perez threw it out to
the authenticator to get authenticated
beauty that breaker it's a big one
and when you get guys looking for that
high heater that's the result you get
when he throws a pitch like that
so ramirez gets to third lintz blocks
him to third
and perez grounds it to dozier ramirez
has nowhere to go
two down so now the number nine hitter
you
chang and now first pitch pop up on the
infield
and it's nikki lopez halfway between the
mound and second base to make the catch
and he does work around the two base hit
after an inning and a half
tribe and royals scoreless loyals have
their lead off man on base
up comes ryan o'hearn look at that threw
it right by him
see he set it up very well on two curve
balls down and then it doesn't have to
be that high above the
belt so the bases are loaded for the guy
you did not want to see
bet in this inning and he grounds one up
the middle the shortstop rosario gloves
fires to first and he got him by a step
bases stay loaded
and savali works out of it but boy did
he have to work
third inning no score cesar will reach
there you go
on the walk third walk issued by lynch
and now he'll face ahmed
rosario grounded to dozier down to a
knee
out at second double play that feels
good for hunter
but watch how soft his hands are right
there okay he sees it all right i loved
it now
transfer and get it over there first man
sure second man quick
here's jose ramirez swing ground ball to
middle fielded by lopez
his throw is in plenty of time daniel
lynch with his most
efficient inning of the night we head to
the bottom of the third
well this a rough start now for savali
two on nobody out
in the heart of the order salvador perez
fly to center but it was a
lengthy at bat his first time up there
it is and
they get one and they cannot turn two
heck of a diving stop by ahmed rosario
to at least take
a hit away and save a run for the moment
and now first and third for jorge soler
he singled his first time up well hit
center field ramirez has to correct
solaire will drive in ben and tendy with
a sacrifice fly and the royals strike
first we head to the fourth
grandma reyes will lead it off hit hard
deep right center field in the gap
and that's gonna one-hot defense brand
meal rolls into second
with a lead-off double now left-hand
batter eddie rosario
who bunts and it gets by the mound
and the royals getting out on a
tremendous play
second base umpire was in his way and he
couldn't get out of the way
of him hopefully he's all right a
two-out chance for naylor here in the
third
against this rookie but he yaks this one
into the gap
and that'll go to the wall josh naylor
delivers a game-tying hit
with a two-out rbi double here in the
fourth
now roberto perez got him on the inside
corner a late call by dan bellino
the home plate umpire but that's the
second strikeout for daniel lynch he
does give up a run on two hits
this game is tied heading to the bottom
of the fourth inning here in kansas city
it'll be dozier now dozier hits it into
left center field
rosario has to chase it deep and it's
going to get by him
dozier will round second he's going to
head for third and he is
in there with a lead off triple and the
royals hope that
wit meritfill can break that 1-1 tie
well the royals are 0 for
six for the runner and scoring position
and wit
crushes it to left hooking into the
corner
gone for a two run home run there you go
there's the hanging breaker it just spun
wind
barreled it what a nice swing fourth
home run
on the year and the fan makes a great
catch and is there to celebrate
with his son in that beautiful fifth
inning kansas city up three to one you
chang to lead it off
a strikeout against chang and that's
lynch's third
tonight he's guessing you can tell by
the swing
he was not committed to that swing and
look at his fan base
the family right there they're loving it
so with new life cleveland brings up
their best hitter and he singles to left
first and second two down 3-1 royals
you know matthew would love to let him
get into this ending but this is a
really really tough situation to let a
a young man making his major league
debut have to face one of the
hottest hitters in the indians lineup
yep a lot of fans come to their feet
so daniel lynch taken out of the ball
game with two outs here in the fifth
inning for scott barlow
and friend male reyes will be the batter
hard hit ball into left field to base it
the indians are gonna get two
rosario scores here comes ramirez and
we've got a tie ball game his friend
neil reyes
has delivered with a two out two run
single
and friend mill reyes has returned to
the tribe lineup in a big way tonight
he has tied this game at three so now
two on with two out and harold ramirez
coming up
ramirez hits a one hopper out to santana
and that's the inning go to the bottom
of the fifth inning so one on one out
for jorge soleil
swung on ground ball to short rosario to
the back for one
hernandez to first double play side
retired
and we'll head to the sixth inning tied
at three in kansas city
low and in the dirt ball four so the
bases are loaded and here comes ben and
tendy
swung on bounce towards the second
baseman hernandez gobbles it up throws
out ben and tendy
and the inning is over and shaw has come
through again
six in the books so two on and now eddie
rosario gets a chance with two down
high fly ball deep right field so laid
back
he's out our room it's out of here
the two out magic continues for
cleveland
a two out three run homer puts the tribe
on top for the first time tonight
six to three and the indians have gotten
to jacob junis
for three in the seventh and josh naylor
the banner
there's a ball hit deep right field so
led back again
he's at the wall leaps up it's gone it's
off the top of the fence and into the
bullpen for a two-out
two-run homer for josh naylor and the
carnage continues
a five run seventh for the indians
biggest inning of the year
and it's an eight to three indians lead
it is stretch time in kansas city
jorge solaire with one on and one out
well hit center field rosario who just
moved to center is back and it's going
to be over his head
so the royals will get a run back
solaire has his second rbi
and it is 8-4 and they'll bring one of
their workhorses out of the bullpen and
james karencheck
he has been flat brilliant this year has
not
allowed a run in 13 games first pitch to
dozier swung on and belted
down that left field line into the
corner it goes
gone home run hunter dozier on the first
pitch
from karen check he has given up his
first runs
of the year and it's a
dozier bomb that was loud
eighth inning in kansas city so down to
second goes
hernandez ahmed rosario
wit makes a diving play he gets up and
throws him out
that saved a run sure did he had to find
that one
emmanuel clause is coming on now to try
to nail it down for the indians
so the trying run at the plate and 100
ozir 1-2
book it closes the door on kansas city
his sixth save of the year the indians
take the series opener
by a final score of eight to six